[Música]
boa tarde pessoal eu sou ricardo de
cerqueira há mais de 25 anos eu venho
trabalhando assessorando o processo de
desenvolvimento desses 25
aproximadamente uns 13 ligado a
organizações de cooperação é
internacional e nesse período tive a
oportunidade de trabalhar assessorando o
processo de desenvolvimento territorial
e desenvolvimento organizacional seja
empresas privadas em organizações em
órgãos governamentais ou em organizações
do terceiro setor
neste bate papo aqui da gente hoje eu
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
algumas idéias dessa minha experiência
ligado principalmente ao tema
desenvolvimento ao tema liderança e mais
recentemente a formação de lideranças
utilizando as temáticas da alta
performance é algumas idéias centrais
que têm norteado esse trabalho eu
gostaria de destacar inicialmente que
não existe processo de desenvolvimento
sem a formação de lideranças
isso pra mim é uma tese não existe
desenvolvimento sem lideranças é outro
aspecto que eu acho que é fundamental
que a gente tem trabalhado é que o
desenvolvimento é sempre um processo
intencional
não existe desenvolvimento por acaso
mesmo que muitas vezes a empresa acha
que a empresa vizinha se desenvolver
melhor porque teve mais sorte
o que o município município do entorno é
mais desenvolvido porque teve mais sorte
não existe processo de desenvolvimento
casuais
há sempre portar do processo uma
intenção de fazer diferente e nesse
processo de intencionalidade é ganha
força os atores o do território ou as
pessoas que fazem parte da organização
o desenvolvimento é um processo que não
vem de fora para dentro o
desenvolvimento ele é sempre endógeno o
desenvolvimento ele pressupõe a
articulação o protagonismo dos atores
locais
e nesse processo de protagonismo dos
atores locais e ganha força o papel das
lideranças pessoas que são visionárias
que tem claro qual é a visão de futuro
pessoas que são inspiradoras pessoas que
conseguem arregimentar outros atores em
relação a uma causa que são pessoas que
conseguem mobilizar esses apoios locais
em relação a um propósito maior então as
lideranças elas têm um papel fundamental
nos processos de desenvolvimento
quando a gente olha a situação atual eu
tenho o hábito de trabalhar em vários
lugares deste país
eu observo que as pessoas comentam assim
estamos vivendo uma crise de lideranças
a gente observa que muitas lideranças
que estão hoje assumindo os processos
elas não conseguem mobilizar elas não
conseguem formar opinião são muitas
vezes as pessoas de boa vontade que
estão ali é empreendendo tentando levar
o processo à frente mas elas não
conseguem respirar
elas não conseguem formar opinião e
arregimentou das pessoas em relação
àquele propósito esse é um fato muito
comum
outro fato é que as verdadeiras
lideranças elas parecem que estão meio
acanhada ismaila intimidados de fazer
diferente porque tem uma acomodação
muito forte das pessoas que querem que
tem alguém que carrega o piano para elas
como a gente fala
por outro lado mesmo que a situação não
seja tão tão favorável
nós temos sempre pessoas que são
lideranças latentes e que precisam ser
reformadas que precisam ser
desenvolvidas e aí que vai entrar um
pouco o foco da minha fala que é comum
que a gente tem utilizado o as
ferramentas de coaching executivo de
coaching de vida no processo de formação
de lideranças principalmente no que
tange à alta performance e o foco desse
trabalho é sempre a frase de que pra
servir melhor
é preciso estar no alegrado no elevado
grau de excelência
se nós não tivemos energizado se nós não
estivermos bem como é que eu posso
exercer bem o meu papel de líder como eu
posso servir
é interessante como é que começa a
trabalhar a temática com as pessoas de
trabalhar o seu grau de excelência
as pessoas que cercam essa pessoa às
vezes acha que ela está sendo egoísta
que ela está se colocando como a
primeira pessoa da lista dela
e no fundo no fundo quem está sendo
egoísta é a pessoa que se queixa porque
ela gostaria de ser a primeira pessoa da
lista do outro e nós temos que ser o
primeiro da nossa lista para estão no ar
um elevado grau de excelência o de
servir melhor
então esse é um ponto de partida se eu
não tiver um elevado grau de excelência
e não sou capaz de servir melhor então
que interessa na realidade é atuar de
maneira mais inteligente é como é que a
gente desenvolve mecanismos e
estratégias de atuar de trabalhar de
maneira diferente não é trabalhar mais
quando se fala em alta performance
muitas vezes se confunde alta
performance com aumentar o tempo no
trabalho aumentar a produtividade no
trabalho quando é justamente o contrário
é como que a gente pode ter um foco que
é o foco da qualidade de vida
esse objetivo da alta performance como o
que a gente pode desenvolver
comportamentos que nos traga melhor
qualidade de vida e a palavra chave é
desenvolver comportamentos os
comportamentos assim como os músculos se
eles forem treinados a gente consegue
desenvolver essa gente tem um monstro
que a gente exercita mais naturalmente a
gente desenvolve esse músculo a mesma
forma em relação aos comportamentos
observem que aquelas coisas que a gente
faz e faz bem
seguramente nós treinamos muito ao longo
da vida então isso é uma prova de como a
gente pode desenvolver comportamentos e
aí essa perspectiva dada alta
performance tem um tema que é muito
interessante entender o que nós chamamos
de estilo exploratório estilo
exploratório é como que eu explico para
mim mesmo as coisas boas ou ruins que
acontecem comigo como eu explico para
minhas coisas que acontecem comigo
existem dois estilos exploratórios que é
o estilo otimista e ao estilo pessimista
meses nesses estilos por notório nós
vamos considerar três fatos que são
decisivos para definir o estilo
sanatório é a permanência a propagação
ea personalização a permanência tem a
ver com o tempo
quando acontece uma coisa ruim comigo eu
vou dizer assim é sempre assim
sempre acontece dessa forma a gente não
consegue localizá que aquele aquele fato
ele pode ter sido simplesmente pontual
eu acordei um dia acordar aconteceu uma
coisa ruim logo na primeira hora eu
simplesmente digo é sempre assim
outro fato eu deixei os promotores têm a
ver com a propagação acontece uma coisa
eu digo está tudo ruim
uma coisa simples muitas vezes
localizada eu pelo que é específico e
generalistas e um terceiro aspecto que
tem a ver com o estilo exploratório é a
personalização em que eu coloco a
responsabilidade do que aconteceu eu
costumo comentar que cada coisa que
acontece na minha vida eu tenho 13 é
três terços aí que eu como que eu
considero intenso eu sou responsável
segundo o texto o outro responsável pelo
que aconteceu e o terceiro texto o
ambiente é responsável e e se ele me
perguntar eu estou fazendo o meu texto
para que as coisas funcionem bem eu
estou colocando no outro ou colocando no
ambiente
a justificativa para as coisas então o
estilo exploratório ele define um pouco
nosso comportamento se você tem uma
atuação mais otimista e mais pessimista
aí você pergunta e porque é importante
saber isso é uma coisa uma coisa que eu
acho que é interessante é que ser
otimista ou ser pessimista não é uma
característica genética não se nasce
pessimista ou não se nasce otimista
o pessimismo e otimismo são
características aprendidas
nós aprendemos isso dentro da nossa
própria casa através da observação do
comportamento por exemplo da nossa
família ou então a observação do
comportamento de pessoas que são
importantes na nossa vida
então a gente observa observa observa e
termina achando que aquilo é um modo de
atuação
da mesma forma que eu aprendi isso na
infância eu posso reaprender na minha na
minha maturidade e por que é importante
aprender isso tem um estudo que foi
aliás um estudo não tem mais ou menos
uns 500 estudos sobre isso que
demonstram que demonstra que os
otimistas
são pessoas que têm menos
depressão resfriados e infecções ou seja
otimistas em geral têm um sistema
imunológico melhor do que os pessimistas
os otimistas quando atletas eles
resistem melhor derrotas
eles conseguem lidar com o fracasso da
derrota e no caso por exemplo de pessoas
que trabalham com vendas
existe um estudo que mostra que os
vendedores otimistas
eles são de 20 a 40 por cento
vendem mais 24 do que os vendedores
pessimistas
então esse modelo exploratório de ser
pessimista ou otimista tem um impacto
concreto em abril as pessoas
isso é uma coisa que eu acho que seria
que é muito importante pra gente
trabalha com lideranças e que tem a ver
com a melhoria da performance deles
tanto na performance como ser humano
como também na geração de resultados é
do processo que ele está levando à
frente as pessoas de alto desempenho
independente do país de origem têm
comportamentos diferenciados e tem
hábitos semelhantes ou seja isso não é
exclusivo de uma região ou de outra os
estudos mostram que independente da
região que eu nasci que eu me criei os
comportamentos são os mesmos das pessoas
que têm alta performance e
comportamentos são esses
o primeiro passo são pessoas que têm
muita clareza do que querem
são pessoas que são guiadas pela missão
e pela visão de futuro
elas têm muito claro qual é a visão de
futuro dela e qual é o papel dela na
sociedade
outro aspecto é que elas querem
continuar aprendendo a vida inteira são
pessoas abertas ao tempo todo está
aprendendo
elas valorizam a forma como se atingir
as metas
ou seja não é só resultado pelo
resultado qual é um processo que gerou
aquele resultado e isso faz muita
diferença preocupação com processos
éticos com processos inclusivos é então
é isso é uma marca muito forte das
pessoas que têm alta performance e outro
aspecto é dessas pessoas que têm alta
performance é que elas fazem
visualização
quando elas têm um objetivo muito claro
elas conseguem criar um
imagem mental do que elas querem
alcançar ela não só deseja ou não mas
elas têm claro qual é a imagem e isso
ajuda muito no alcance dessa visão de
futuro e último aspecto vou falar um
pouco mais sobre isso é que as pessoas
de alta performance elas têm momentos de
oscilação
vocês podem perceber que todo mundo que
tem alto desempenho
eles não sofrem por exemplo de clientes
de crise de bailout não são pessoas que
se esgotam porque elas oscilam e o que a
oscilação
eu vou dar um exemplo você passa o dia
inteiro fazendo um trabalho que exige
muito da sua cabeça um trabalho
intelectual chega no fim da tarde você
tá super cansado cabeça quente
e aí você pensa eu vou dormir eu vou
sentar para ver televisão para descansar
minha cabeça mas o que é o cansaço na
realidade o cansaço é excesso de energia
acumulado em uma parte do corpo
nesse meu exemplo o cansaço é excesso de
energia acumulado no cérebro e se eu
quero descansar e eu deito eu não vou
conseguir distribuir distribuir energia
que está concentrada
então o que eu tenho que fazer eu tenho
pior se lá o que significa então o se lá
por exemplo se eu faço uma atividade
física que gere calor que gere
transpiração eu faço com que a energia
que estava concentrada em uma parte do
meu corpo ela se distribua pelo corpo
como um todo eu assinalo então as
pessoas que têm estafa que tem é é tão
com essa crise que chama de barriga de
esgotamento físico e mental pode
observar se elas fazem isso
possivelmente não fazem porque as
pessoas que têm alta performance elas
conseguem equilibrar essas dimensões
todas para ter resultados positivos em
todos os aspectos da vida então a
situação é um é uma característica
fundamental de quem tem alta performance
no caso de pessoas com atletas que o
desgaste deles é mais físico a oscilação
é o contrário ele trabalha o dia inteiro
com o corpo exercitam ano
de noite ele oscila como deitado vendo
televisão porque distribuem energia que
está concentrada nos músculos
então a simulação aspecto fundamental no
processo de
é desenvolvimento de comportamento de
alta performance
o último vídeo que irá abordar que tem a
ver com a performance também é questão
de foco
os estudos mostram que não existem
pessoas multifocais eu sempre acho uma
pessoa multifocal eu achei que
conseguiria fazer um monte de coisas ao
mesmo tempo e hoje me dou conta de
quando eu faço muitas coisas mesmo tempo
eu me distraio e no foco no que é
essencial os estudos da psicologia
positiva hoje demonstram que o cérebro
da gente não consegue ter mais um foco
de vez
então é fundamental que a gente evite as
distrações e as distrações podem ser
internas com pensamentos negativos com
for com pensamento e outras coisas que
não é o central e podem ser também é
distrações no próprio ambiente trabalhar
em salas barulhentas trabalhar em salas
que pessoas entram e saem que têm algum
tipo de coisa que lhe tira a tensão e
isso te distraem e tira o foco então
assim preparar o ambiente para trabalhar
e preparar a mente para trabalhar
ela ajuda muito na questão do fogo então
esses aspectos que eu estou trazendo
aqui pra vocês em relação à alta
performance
são temas que nesses meus 25 anos de
trabalho eu tenho eu tenho trabalhado
muito ultimamente tanto na formação de
desenvolvimento de times de equipes como
também na formação de líderes
especificamente e eu percebo avanços
significativos tanto na mudança de
comportamento dessas pessoas como na
geração de resultados do papel de
liderança tanto nas empresas como nas
regiões como nos municípios e eu
gostaria de encerrar com uma frase que
eu gosto muito é do charlie chaplin que
não chama a atenção do lado humano da
gente que não pode perder nunca em tudo
isso que a gente nunca pode perder
humanidade que essa frase que diz não
somos máquina homens é o que sois então
que a gente nunca perca humanidade e que
a gente possa sempre avançando na busca
de comportamentos que garanta cada vez
mais esse lado humano que todos nós
temos muito obrigado
[Aplausos]